hi there today we're looking at planning
to explore via self supervised world
models by Raman on Sekar all a ripken
Kostas Danny Lee this Pietra Biel
donnager Hafner and Deepak Patek so this
is a paper that concerns reinforcement
learning and specifically sort of self
supervised reinforcement learning so
what do they mean there's a graphic
right here in reinforcement learning
usually you have an environment and an
agent right so you have this environment
and let's ignore the without rewards for
now and you have the agent and the agent
needs to interact with the environment
in order to achieve a maximum reward so
the reward is given by a certain task
right you have to do something in this
environment in this case they consider
these these types of tasks where I think
the top task might be called run forward
so your reward is more the further you
go with this Walker and how you can
influence the Walker is you can sort of
give give a bit of force onto its joints
right here then you have a bunch of
sensors of the main task is actually to
keep it to balance it on its feet and
then sort of walk forward such that it
never falls over right otherwise you get
negative reward you lose so in this case
what they want to do is they want to say
wait if we just train a reinforcement
learning agent for each of these tasks
individually that will use a lot of data
and basically we can't reuse the learned
reinforcement learning agent for each of
these individual tasks it's sort of like
if you have many you know image tasks or
NLP tasks you don't want to learn one
model for each one individually but you
might do something like a common joint
pre-training and this is exactly this
for reinforcement learning and it's even
called self supervised right like we are
used to in the in the classification
setting self supervised learning what
does it mean so it means that at first
you're in an environment without rewards
so basically the agent is just dropped
in an environment and there's no rewards
it can just do actions and observes of
the states from this environment and
after that after a while of that then
the tasks come in so task a task B and
task C are 3 different tasks all in the
same environment but all requiring the
agent to do different things like
running forward or running backwards or
do a front-flip
or things like this so the how fast the
agent can adapt to these individual
tasks very much depends on what it has
learned during this phase where there
were no rewards right so the agent is
tasked to just explore the world via
what they call here task agnostic
exploration to explore the world to
learn something about the world in order
then to generalize to these stat tasks
and in their case they learn this global
world model so the agent is supposed to
learn somehow how the world works right
and this is this is the way that this
agent is then able to adapt really
quickly so in essence what does this
agent do the agent works as follows
it gets an input observation and it runs
that through an encoder which is usually
something like a convolutional neural
network and that will give you a set of
features right so this is sort of an
embedding of the state that you're in
and that you can incorporate into a
latent State at time T now usually in
these RL algorithms or what can happen
is that you incorporate the last leijen
latent States so the latent state from
the step here also goes into the latent
state of the next step right so here was
the sorry the last observation
observation comes in features latent
state and so on
ultimately and then and so on and comes
in from here and there's usually like an
RNN going over the time steps but
ultimately here the agent has to decide
on an action using this policy network
now how is this trained to this policy
network has to come up with an action
but there are no rewards so usually we
would train this policy network with
like an actor critic method so we would
also train some sort of a value function
and then the policy would try to
maximize the value function and but if
we don't have rewards how are we gonna
do that
so people have thought about this for a
bit and people have come up with things
like intrinsic motivation intrinsic
motivation is a term where you're trying
to say something like if you're in a
room right here like this your agent is
right here then you just you know you do
something and maybe your agent goes down
here if your agent were to go down there
again it would sort of not really learn
anything because it has now already gone
there there's already learned from those
states so you might want to explore some
different space right like here and in
the next episode you might want to
explore this room right here
so it's this notion of intrinsic
motivation to explore it has a bunch of
different formulations of how exactly
you can formulate it but just imagine
basically the entire state is filled
with a bunch of coins and I'm gonna draw
this as green dots sort of like pac-man
and everything is filled with these
green dots right and what the agent
wants to do if it has no rewards it will
simply collect those green dots and once
one is collected so if I go here I'll
collect all these green dots these are
now no longer there so that area doesn't
give me any reward anymore so you can
imagine sort of like this
so as an intrinsic reward you simply
reward the agent every time it finds
itself in a new state that it hasn't
seen before so you train it you seek out
novel states that usually when you just
have like an actor critic method and
that's what this paper here criticizes
if you have it it's called retrospective
novelty that means if you train a model
free I'll algorithm which is an actor
critic right if we just plug in into
here something like a three-c that will
simply have a policy and a value
function and in this case if we train it
on intrinsic reward the policy will
simply tell you where to go to find more
green stuff but you can only train it so
you use this to run an episode and then
you observe how many green things you
found in that episode right if your
episode goes here and then you put that
back into your buffer to learn from but
at that point you've already collected
the green things right so the reward
signal is actually a bit off because you
want to train your agent that there that
it should seek out novel things but as
soon as you've explored them they're not
really novel anymore because you have
now explored them but still you're going
to train your agent telling your agents
that this area right here has lots of
has given me lots of rewards so the
agents going to be encouraged to repeat
that they they say this right here the
retrospective novelty model free
exploration methods not only require
large amounts of experience to adapt to
downstream tasks they can also be
inefficient during exploration these
agent usually first act in the
environment collect trajectories and
then calculate an intrinsic reward as
the agents current estimate of novelty
this approach misses out on efficiency
by operating retrospectively that is the
novelty of inputs is computed after the
agent has already reached them
hence it seeks out previously novel
inputs that have already been visited
and would not be novel anymore
instead one should directly seek out
future inputs that are expected to be
novel now so what this paper is doing
it's basically saying can we build a
model that estimates the future novelty
of a state that we maybe haven't seen so
far and here is where that goes
so what do they do in this policy so the
policy isn't just trained to maximize
the novelty in the world instead sorry
it uses planning it uses planning in
latent space so what this model does is
it learns a world model in latent space
the world model takes as input these
features that you saw right here like
the encoder gives you and it predicts
the future hid hidden latent states
these are the things you saw here so
these things that are always made by
incorporating the new features with the
old state it tries to predict it
so technically these things here should
have like a some sort of a now this is
actually exact here but these here
should have some sort of a tick or
something to indicate these are or
estimated these are estimated future
states and this model right here this is
an estimate this is a world model they
use dreamer for this and I have made a
video about dreamer dreamer tries
exactly that it tries to estimate what
is the future but not in actual world
space but in latent space and yeah so it
tries to estimate its own future and the
cool thing here is that this is
probabilistic or you can make it
probabilistic so you can technically
from this 1h that you have here you can
run out many futures in your imagination
and since you don't need the
observations you only need the latent
space you can simply forward roll your
RNN and sample from it and you have many
trajectories in the future now the fact
that you have many trajectories leads to
even a different thing so what you can
do for each of these hidden states they
have a head here that predicts the so
called latent disagreement what does
this do this consists of a whole bunch
of models these are ensemble models
they're the same for each time step but
what they take in they take in the
latent state of the model and the action
that you're about to do the action that
you imagine you would do right so this
is the imagined state and this is the
imagined action in that state and then
it will compute the next features so the
next whatever in the next step would be
the H so right right where do we put it
whatever in the next so if I have this H
and I have this state it tells me if I
do action a 1 and if I were to execute
this in the real world what would be my
next H that I would get so basically by
performing an action I will get the next
observation and I will encode that to
get the next features and this small
model would try to predict what are the
features of the next state if I were to
execute this action in this state okay
so it's kind of a future predictor but
also not in observation space but in
latent space so it tries to predict the
latent features of the next observation
and the displayed here you might think
that there is bit of it it's it's like
almost the same this latent state here
and the features but as we discussed
before the latent state can incorporate
the last or
history of Layton States while the
features simply are only a function of
the current observation and that's why
they predict the features they really
want to predict the observation but
history has sort of shown that if you
try to predict for example the pixels of
the observation that won't serve you
really well and therefore what you need
to do is you need to predict the latent
features of the observation that works
much better so they have a bunch of
these models right here they have a
bunch of models with different
parameterizations they instantiate k
different models of that and they all
run the same so these are all the same
inputs through these different models
now these different models have been
initialized at different points so they
will make slightly different predictions
and the crucial part is so if if it's
really deterministic what the next state
is going to be right so say you're in
this state you would perform this action
and so if you have a ball in your hand
and you drop the ball then the ball is
gonna fall down really deterministic
that means these next these estimated
next features if the models are any good
they all agree and this variance here
between the estimates is very very small
and now if if the uncertainty over the
next state is very high and this can be
due to two facts either it is actually
uncertain what's gonna happen so maybe
you have a really a piece of paper and
you drop that and due to the wind you
can't know what's happening or because
your model has simply not learned yet
what's gonna happen in either of those
cases you don't know what's going to
happen
therefore these these predictions here
sorry are going to be very different
from each other and because of that this
variance will be high and this variance
you take as the intrinsic reward so in
each step you basically try to predict
over the next
actions you can do which ones leads me
to a leads me to a situation where I
don't know what's going to happen where
I cannot really predict the variance in
my prediction is high so I really don't
know what's gonna happen and that is
going to be the states you seek out okay
so this is the core of the paper
basically you do this planning in latent
space in order to find the states or
action that leads you to a state where
you don't know what's going to happen
and you measure that by trying to
predict it using slightly different
models and if they disagree a whole
bunch then you can use you sort of you
say I don't know what's going to happen
and therefore I want to go there because
I want to learn about that state now
this this is the this is the entire
thing it has a bunch of problems as you
can imagine so this is the reasoning
behind it right now they try to make a a
deal out of basically their Layton's
disagreement here agrees with minimize X
sorry maximizing the expected
information game they go into the theory
right here and say okay if I have a
state and an action and I had and this w
or the dynamics parameters of the world
so the W characterizes how the world
works and the H here is the next state
to the features of the next observation
and the AI is the mutual information
between H and W so this right here
measures how much in from information of
the next state is contained in the
dynamics of the world if this is really
low and I have a good world model then I
should be able to predict the next state
really well and this this they say okay
selecting the most promising data during
exploration
we want to select the action that
maximizes this information game so the
the more the mutual information here we
want to select the action that maximizes
that they decompose this mutual
information into two things they
decompose it into this thing right here
which is simply the entropy of the next
state given the current state and action
this is simply the total uncertainty
including the fact that it could
actually be stochastic like dropping a
paper and the fact that you haven't
learned yet what happens like if you
drop a ball but you haven't learned that
yet that is also uncertain so this is
that part assisted total uncertainty -
this right here and this is the
uncertainty if you know the dynamics
right so this is the the wind basically
in the paper example so you want
something where the total uncertainty is
high but the the kind of uncertainty of
the of the stochasticity of the world is
low if you maximize this quantity here
this in total quantity sorry if you
maximize this entire quantity because I
called one of them total that means you
are going to seek out actions where
what's left is only the uncertainty that
you yourself don't know right you say
well this state has a pretty high total
uncertainty but it's not due to the fact
that the world itself is uncertain it
must be due to the fact that I don't
know yet and they make the claim that
their model is actually going after
these things and they say okay because
we have these these gaussians here as
our estimators they somehow reduce to
this total to this uncertainty but only
basically by taking Gao since they
assume they just assume
that this quantity here is constant at
least that's how I understand it they
basically assume that every transition
in the world has about the same amount
of uncertainty and therefore we can just
focus on the total amount of uncertainty
right so if we can't predict if we can't
predict it in the next state a if we can
predict the next state a better than the
next state B and both have about the
same amount of intrinsic uncertainty
stochasticity in the world that must
mean we should go to B because that's
where our model hasn't learned yet now
of course in the real world that is
absolutely not the case
and I think this model works mainly
because they test it in these
transitions or in these environments
where that might be very close to
accurate that actually most of the
transitions have the same stochasticity
as any other transition the second the
second part why this is a bit difficult
is because you have to somehow keep this
latent sorry this this couple of models
right here that make this disagreement
prediction so you rely on the fact that
you can capture disagreement by looking
how those models disagree with each
other and again they employ gaussians
here but it is not said that these
things these things will actually give
you the true disagreement among
themselves if you initialize them
wrongly they they might miss like if if
your distribution has three modes they
act they might just for all of them
focus on one of them and then your
disagreement will be completely out of
whack or you could initialize them not
far enough for or too close together
that's the same thing okay so it all
depends on kind of how you manage to to
handle this uncertainty right here so
all of this seems a bit problematic but
the whole setup is pretty cool
because imagine like all of this is
shifting constantly right the the the
policy here tries to maximize these
rewards and this is something I don't
understand in the paper they make it
sort of explicitly clear that the policy
tries to maximize this quantity right
here
the next uncertainty right the planning
objective is to maximize expected
novelty RIT which is this thing right
here however I I don't actually see why
in that case you need planning because
with planning your goal is sort of to
look ahead and more than one step so
what I would expect is that they somehow
have the aggregated so somehow that they
not don't maximize this but somehow they
maximize the future right of T prime of
RT prime I they somehow maximize the yes
they somehow maximize the future the
total future maybe with a disagreement
like if it was a reward and you actually
want to maximize the total reward across
your episode I would imagine they use
planning to maximize the total future
uncertainty that they encounter because
right here you have your trajectories
and as they say it they only maximize
the uncertainty after the first step so
this here might be you know even
intrinsically uncertain or a bit
uncertain but if you go down the path
here there might be a state where that's
super uncertain and you would like to
find that right through your different
rollouts so I'm not sure that the paper
is correct or consistent here actually I
might be wrong though they do have the
code which is a really good thing so
I'll link to the code and you can go and
explore that they do have this algorithm
down here which is pretty much I mean
this is saying just nothing while
exploring do train the world model
trained the latent disagreement ensemble
train the policy in imagination of like
rather rather it helps a bit okay but
one other thing right here the policy
that tries to maximize the reward right
you so you use planning to look ahead
where the uncertainty is but how do you
do the planning you need the you need a
policy in imagination space right this
latent disagreement policy here is used
to train em how you act in latent space
right how this action that you imagined
comes to be you can't plan in
imagination space and in imagination
space use planning again is just an
infinite recursion at some point you
need a model that tells you what to do
and in imagination they just use an
actor critic model you see they have a
value function here they just use an
actor critic model to basically one-shot
predict the next best the next best
action to get you to the next step so as
they themselves rack on these model free
methods because they only look ahead how
is that not exactly the same as me
ragging on the fact that they use model
free and imagination space because your
world model certainly is retrospective
you're a world model learns from the
past right so the model free method that
learns on your imagined world model
learns from retrospective imagination
and therefore itself has sort of the
same problem just one layer deeper that
it learns from retrospective data and
not from data ahead because your
uncertainty about the future might just
be because of your retrospect exactly is
because of your at respective data now
see the value in having this uncertainty
but I think there are other methods that
also do model free
and don't just maximize an intrinsic
reward but actually maximize a sort of
uncertainty okay enough ragging let's go
to the experiment so the cool thing you
can do with this is what's called zero
shot performance so so what they do is
in a first step they do this they just
learn task agnostic just Explorer
without a task then second they go and
into their buffer so when they explore
they all save they save what they do
there is no reward but they just save
they store their episodes right and then
then someone comes with a task and the
task is simply they specify like you
have to run forward and they go to this
buffer and they now label every episode
with its reward so this is different
this is like offline reinforcement
learning right so basically it is it is
how well they call it zero shot but it
is how well can an algorithm that has
explored with self with this kind of
self supervision perform in in offline
reinforcement learning on the
trajectories that it has already
experienced which is different from
performing the same trajectories in in
with the reward because you would you
would learn from the reward and you
would learn to seek out different like
your experience would be different if
you were going after a reward so this is
harder so they compared this to dreamer
and dreamer sorry is a fully supervised
method the dreamer is actually cheating
dreamer actually goes after the reward
and all the other methods here they
don't have a reward and they're just
zero shot offline reinforcement learning
generalized to these methods and you see
the green is the plan to explore and
that X that outperforms almost all the
other methods right here down here
and even comes close to this to the
dreamer that goes up here it seemed
pretty much every graphic that dreamer
is the one that's able to cheat right so
it is performing pretty well but then
the zero shot generalized plan to
explore is sometimes on par and
certainly outperforms the other
intrinsic reward methods now how does
that go about when you try actually when
you allow the model to fine-tune on the
task so here is performance on few shot
adaptation from raw pixels without
states based input so basically you
learn without reward for this many steps
right here until this shaded area back
here this is how when you do no reward
and then all of a sudden now you say
okay now I'll give you reward now please
learn now you have this many steps you
have this many steps where you can learn
from the reward so now we're no longer
in this offline or ell setting this is
now online RL but we've been pre trained
with all of this experience that we had
without the reward again the orange here
is the cheater so the orange is is
cheating and now we don't so before the
crafts were higher because we've we've
actually at each step for example how
this works is you train until here
without reward and then you do this
offline or L offline or L training and
that's how this point comes about now I
think in the graph down here they they
don't do that so they just measure how
well you're doing in the task and of
course if after this many steps you've
never looked at the reward you haven't
been able to look at the reward your
reward will be fairly low right at the
task because you don't know what to do
to get a higher reward
the dreamer again this orange line is
able to cheat that's why I just is
basically straight line or goes up at
the beginning it's able to look at the
reward from the beginning and it's here
as a baseline comparison so you see as
soon as you give the reward to the
models they generally shoot up and this
plan to explore generally shoots up much
harder than these others as you can see
pretty much everywhere and again it gets
competitive and here even outperforms
the dreamer why could it outperform the
supervised method maybe because these
this method here is sort of confused
or is stuck in a local optimum which can
happen very easily in reinforcement
learning whereas the plan to explore has
never seen the reward
therefore hasn't tried to just single
mindedly maximize the reward and has
explored a bunch of different things to
do in the world and now we can use that
knowledge to outperform the plan the
dreamer the baseline so the other thing
I would like to draw your attention to
here is that sometimes you see that the
plan to explore or the other curiosity
methods actually get a reward before the
reward kicks in as we saw here right
it's for example right here and this
tells me that this is probably a
property of the environment itself
namely these reinforcement learning
environments they're they don't really
have much noise going on right they
pretty much just have it's a simulator
with one figure that can walk or not and
therefore it might be that the only
interesting thing to do in these models
is to actually perform one of these
tasks and that's why it might be that
the sometimes you they already get a
reward so it is true that they don't see
the reward for this entire duration but
also implicitly via the developers
building the simulator they have made it
such that the only entry
thing thing to do is the same thing as
getting a reward right so I'm sort of
skeptical that this is like a general
exploration policy because also in the
real world there are just combinatoric
lis hugely many many actions to do many
paths to follow and if you just go by
what do I not know yet I think you can't
you can't put that all into one model
it's just too much and the states where
you really were really something
interesting happens are so few and far
in between and that it doesn't compare
to the amount of states where you simply
don't know most states you don't know
what's gonna happen but probably
nothing's nothing interesting is going
to happen just different things which
will screw over this method completely
in any case they yeah sorry this is just
this is another experiment they have a
bunch of other experiments and yeah that
that was my this was my review of the
paper tell me if you agree or disagree
or if I've misunderstood something
that's entirely possible I'm just always
a bit skeptical of these things a bit so
the experiments they're very compute
intensive of course so you never know
there and then these specific
environments right here
you never know there and then the fact
that the real world actually has very
different stochasticity which they
simply assume away right here yeah but
other than that big props the to the
fact that the code is out and as I said
leave a comment if you agree or disagree
please subscribe and share this video if
you liked it and I'll see you next time
bye bye